so I really want to spend some time
today talking about what is now at first
we suspected it but it's now very clear
is the real possibility of violence I'm
talking about physical violence if
Donald Trump were to lose in November
and this is I don't really want to make
this about Trump because it's not this
really ties together sort of the faux
populist rhetoric that I've been warning
about it ties together Fox News in the
propaganda space and in order to talk
about this today we're gonna look at a
clip from Tucker Carlson's program on
Monday I believe it was on Monday night
and what I want you to consider here is
not just the growing influence of Tucker
Carlson and in fact there are people now
talking about what about Tucker for
president in 2024 if Trump can be
President certainly at least
theoretically Tucker Carlson could be
President of the United States and I
know that that will be very very scary
to many of you but I also want to use
the clips we're going to look at today
as a sort of case study in how the media
propaganda cycle works and how it will
completely reverse reality and take
advantage of the lack of education and
critical thinking skills that are part
of what got Donald Trump elected in the
first place so Tucker Carlson is no
longer playing coy he is straight up
saying the left is dangerous the left
hates America and the left is a
fundamental threat to the way of life
that Tucker
I guess espouses through his faux
populist rhetoric Tucker Carlson in
doing this is setting the stage for
violence if Donald Trump loses he's both
planting the seed of the idea in the
minds of right-wingers and he's giving
right-wingers justification for doing
violence if Joe Biden were to get
elected in November and the the sort of
crux of it is the left hates America the
left despises this country and we're
going to look at a segment it was a
15-minute segment we're going to look at
some different pieces of it and after
opening up this segment by talking about
how the Left only hates Trump because
they
control him not because he's incompetent
not because he's actively damaging the
United States every single day Tucker
says the left just hates Trump because
they can't control him he's a free
thinker he's an independent mind he
starts to weave us through this left
hates America idea by saying it starts
in school school kids aren't taught the
history of Mount Rushmore and Thomas
Jefferson that Donald Trump talked about
at his July 3rd Mount Rushmore speech
and they're not taught about how the
u.s. is a force for good that defeated
fascism and communism it starts in
school Tucker Carlson says take a look
yet as the president pointed out
American school children learn virtually
none of this instead our curricula have
become a toxic mix of lies in omission
all of it designed to poison our
children against the country that formed
them against every law of society in
nature our children are taught in school
to hate their own country and to believe
that the men and women who built it
we're not heroes but that were villains
the radical view of American history is
a web of lies all perspective is removed
every virtue is obscured every motive is
twisted every fact is distorted and
every flaw is magnified until the
history is purged and the record is
disfigured beyond all recognition every
word of that is true if you have kids in
school you know it may even be
understatement what is happening in our
classrooms right now in 2020 is a crime
it is long past time that a sitting
president said so so why am i starting
with the stuff about schools why is
Tucker starting with the stuff about
schools this is how you start priming
the right towards violence our schools
have been taken over by liberal lies and
liberal liars Trump is saying it and
Tucker is willing to say it and that's
the framework for what is going to come
now the reason
this is so pernicious is that our
schools are failing it is true that much
of our education system is not working
but it's failing as evidenced by Trump
being elected in other words it's
failing as evidenced by 60 plus million
people falling for the obviously false
talking points of the Trump campaign in
2015 and 2016 and voting for him so
there's a big problem with our schools
but the problem isn't our kids are being
taught what what I guess Tucker and
Trump say is some incorrect version of
history our schools are failing and that
American students are falling further
and further behind behind in math and
science compared to many other countries
our schools are failing in that critical
thinking and civics and media literacy
are all but gone unless you're like
really lucky or seek them out at some
narrow slice of the School of Public
Schools and because of that sixty
million americans voted for Donald Trump
but people fall for stuff like we have
15 cases of coronavirus which will soon
be zero right that that's the evidence
that education is failing people fall
for these bogus tax cuts that are really
you get a little more money in your
paycheck but your refund is smaller at
the end of the year millions of people
fell for that so this is how Tucker lays
the groundwork schools cannot be trusted
in schools are ruining our kids and
turning them against our country now we
go to the next part of this monologue
skipping ahead a couple of minutes
Tucker starts ginning up the hatred with
dog whistles starts up again with the
violent protests check out how he
transitions here if you spent the rest
of your life trying to locate to
identify the worst people in this
country of 330 million you couldn't get
a pure distillation than what you just
saw these people are liars they're the
same people who spent the last month
telling you that the riots you saw live
on television were actually peaceful
protests against racism that was a lie
they knew it was a lie when they said it
but they said it anyway in order to
undermine a country that they hate yes
hey America deserves
to be in flames that is their view and
this weekend they said it essentially
out loud no one said that riots and
looting were peaceful protesting what we
said was which is true we had
overwhelmingly peaceful protests against
police brutality and in addition to that
there were some looters and there were
some rioters and I can only speak for
myself but I didn't say that that was
evidence of peaceful protesting the
peaceful protesting was peaceful
protesting the other stuff was other
things but now you see the big picture
the narrative that Tucker Carlson is
weaving and I admit it he does it well
these are well scripted monologues where
listen schools are teaching kids to hate
America that was part one then those
kids become left-wing rioters who go out
and destroy our cities because they've
been taught to hate America so he's
building up the justification for
violence if Donald Trump were to lose
and then he goes fully into it the left
hates America that is the next part of
the message and if Tucker convinces his
audience that the left hates America
violence against the left in their eyes
would be justified because it would be
protecting America and that's where
Tucker keeps going and comes full circle
now with Joe Biden this is a clever
monologue this is you know because a lot
of the people who watch these programs
lack the basic critical thinking and
epistemology skills and media literacy
skills this is a far more clever
monologue than most of Tucker's viewers
are going to be able to pick apart for
what it is you start with our schools
teach kids to hate which has led the
left to hate America and go and riot and
then that same left who hates America
wants to elect Joe Biden and that's how
he links it all together to Joe Biden
and lays the groundwork for violence if
Biden wins take a look so where's Joe
Biden on all of this as the revolution
continues apace Biden is supposed to be
a moderate remember that was his chief
appeal but there was nothing moderate
about Biden's fourth of July statement
instead it was a full-throated attack on
the United States our country was
founded on an idea
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal
I've never lived up to it Jefferson
himself did he held slaves women were
excluded American history is no fairy
tale it's been a constant push and pull
between
two parts of our character the idea that
all men and women all people are created
equal and the racism that has torn us
apart we have a chance to rip the roots
of systemic racism out of this country
that's your fourth of July message
systemic racism something you can't even
define that has no real definition
really wagging your finger in the face
of the nation that promoted someone is
mediocre as you to the position you
currently hold this is the man who could
soon be our figurehead so now you've
seen the full path the left hates our
country because schools are teaching
them to after learning to hate the
country they go out and attack the
country by rioting and looting and then
they will support Joe Biden who is
supportive of that America hatred and
rioting and looting he's suggesting the
imagery of a Joe Biden presidency as a
presidency equivalent to tantamount to
hating America and rioting and looting
and then on the tail end
Tucker wraps it up with this sort of
faux modest statement of you know on
this program we really try not to
question people's patriotism because
that's a really serious thing to do but
we have to because clearly these people
hate the country take a look at that so
what a make of all of this well it's
long been considered out of bounds to
question a person's patriotism it's a
very strong charge and we try not ever
to make it but in the face of all of
this the conclusion can't be avoided
these people actually hate America
there's no longer a question about that
and yet paradoxically at the same time
they desperately want to control America
more than anything and that leads to the
most basic of all questions can you
really lead a country that you hate ask
yourself what kind of parent would you
be if you hated your children what kind
of officer would you make if you didn't
care about your troops it would be awful
the results would be ugly it would not
work loving the people you lead carrying
deep
about them is the most basic
prerequisite of leadership the leaders
of today's democratic party do not they
despise this country they have said so
they continue to that is shocking but it
is also disqualifying we cannot let them
run this nation because they hate it
imagine what they would do to it they
hate America is the fundamental message
so the right is falling for this hook
line and sinker and it is so unhinged
that it actually could bring the right
to violence if Joe Biden wins if you
believe Tucker about this if you sit
there for the thirteen and a half
minutes or however long it is and you
not along and you say yeah schools are
teaching hid kids to become protesters
who riot and then elect Joe Biden if
Trump loses on November 3rd and you
believe that you might feel justified in
going out with your guns to try to put a
stop to this America hatred from the
left and this gets us back to something
that I've now had to bring up three or
four times which is the populist
rhetoric bamboozles people when I talked
a few six weeks ago maybe about how I'm
worried that left populist rhetoric may
be replacing the actual set of ideas
that is social democracy the main
concern was the rhetoric sounds pretty
damn good and it's very similar rhetoric
from left to right when it comes to
populism the middle class is the core of
this country and we need to support the
average person and all of this different
stuff this is exactly what I'm talking
about because then they slip in the
prescription which is no leftists
conservative school agendas no
immigrants black lives matter will take
your house the prescription is
absolutely bonkers and notice that
Tucker doesn't talk about policy and
when Tucker bragged in the monologue I
don't know if I played it but it was in
the monologue Tucker said Trump's speech
at Mount Rushmore was one of the best of
his presidency Tucker said you'll notice
that that speech at Mount Rushmore had
essentially no policy ideas it was Trump
railing against Marxists who
exist there's no prominent Marxist that
Trump is reasonably fighting against he
railed against anarchists on the Left he
railed against people who teach our kids
to hate America there were no lists
there was no list of accomplishments of
what Trump did other than you know lies
about defeating the virus which we
clearly haven't done and there was no
sort of a guidebook for what you would
get policy wise from Trump in his second
term this is the epitome of being
bamboozled by populist rhetoric no
policy and Tucker says that was a great
speech Trump really laid it out all
Trump laid out is an imaginary enemy a
straw man from the left of these violent
Marxist anarchists which don't exist and
then Trump then has the benefit of
Tucker going to his audience and saying
that was a great speech it was an
amazingly good speech that Donald Trump
gave all Trump said is the left is
radical and hates everybody in blah blah
blah and respect our heritage again
another illusion to Confederate statues
in the Confederate flag so this is
extremely dangerous and it's
particularly dangerous for two reasons
one I I don't I'm not trying to insult
people when I say this but the lack of
critical thinking and and media literacy
skills in this country makes this stuff
really effective that monologue already
has like a million and a half views on
YouTube and there are people on the
right and even some on the left who are
getting tricked into sharing this Tucker
Carlson stuff so we've got to do
something about it I don't even know
what it is because the audience that he
is catering to with this garbage is ripe
for it they're not going to then come
and watch me spend 15 minutes explaining
to you how you're being bamboozled by
this so I if I don't sound optimistic
it's because I'm not I don't know what
the solution is and it's extraordinarily
dangerous what's going on I want to hear
your thoughts about it I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman remember that you can get the
full audio podcast of the show every day
on whatever your favorite podcasting
platform is be it Spotify or Pandora or
iTunes or Google Play it's free get the
daily podcast and the next Tuesday two
big things
on Tuesday number one the third david
pakman show chess tournament at 8:00
p.m. Eastern on Tuesday you can register
for free at david pakman.com slash chess
and then number two we took a big hit on
memberships in the last week we're
trying to dig out from a hole of like
300 cancellations so Tuesday the same
day as the chess tournament we're going
to do a one-day membership special where
we will email out to everybody on our
mailing list a very exclusive one-day
discount code buy exclusive it just
means you've got to be getting our
newsletter you can sign up to be
notified on david pakman.com upper right
of the website type in your email
address sign up for the newsletter you
will be notified very powerfully on
Tuesday and then I hope you'll join us
for the chess tournament as well